yesterday we were looking at what kind
of physical situation yesterday vectra
bag tracks very good so you've got an
embankment and invade but that's just
another name for this thing and in fact
that we've raised one side so if you go
car that's coming around a corner okay
rather than solely relying on friction
salting rely on friction to push you
into the center of the turn because
remember there's got to be a net force
of arm mr omega squared or MV square on
our in toward the center in addition to
the friction what you've got is because
this is tilted what forces change
direction now that we've tilted this
what force has changed direction it's
the normal force right instead just
being straight up now it's off in this
direction ok so just Rover this movie
you've got your normal facing off that
way so now what's wonderful about this
is that the horizontal component of this
normal force contributes to warn you
know into the center ok and we worked
out our there's enough to move his feet
where that will go that will give
exactly the right now to force you need
to take you around the coin of course
these are not the only forces involved
in the situation what are we forced
apart from that all force what are the
other two ok bet the most obvious one
first is gravity that means pretty much
always sort of hanging around there and
if you want the one going at the exact
optimus v ok then friction will be
involved right I done if you're not
going fast enough if you're not going
fast enough friction is going to wait
yeah if you are not going fast enough if
you're not going fast enough then your
vehicle wants to slide down the
embankment to therefore friction is what
holds you up right so the lateral force
and that's what i define is the positive
direction but you can define it the
other way if you like it text books
often to find the other way to avoid new
zones or alternatively if you're going
too fast the lateral force is what's
doing its previous job of you actually
keeping you in the turn so that's why
pulls you toward the center so so far so
good ok now this situation of a car on a
bait track feels very very similar
conceptually to another vehicle that is
making another kinds of turn and is also
on an angle namely do it I'm not able to
get air resistance into the internment i
thinkI of these guys okay my colors a
bit off but anyway we'll do it gear so
yeah so here here's a bunch of cyclist
taking a corner I know it's a bit dim
but you can see what's happening right
and what's lovely about this is you can
see all of them and they have to do this
same leaning me right now we know we
know and i'll see if i can put the video
i don't worry about that too much it's
okay we know that if you want to take
this corner faster right or if it's got
a very small radius right what would
happen to this this angle theta here if
I want to increase velocity remember
this is we want every squared on arm
right so if I want to increase velocity
or decrease the radius right so go
faster we'll have a sharper turn right
what happens to feed up think about it
think about it um what this means is V
squared get V getting bigger or are
getting smaller this total thing is
going to get larger in magnitude right
larger in magnitude because that's all
the numeric that's on the denominator so
that means I need more things pushing me
toward the center so see this normal
force at the urban right on a flat road
it's gone up this way the more i incline
the embankment the more it's going to
point off in this direction does that
make sense so in other words big of a
small R I want a greater angle and like
this to be steeper does that make sense
so that's why if you're going really
really fast around a really sharp corner
in fact this time just for a second of
all turn off lights I don't want my
colors like that but I hope you can see
like that is the and his elbow right and
they are like centimeters off the ground
okay so this corresponds to a really
really steep like think about think
about what this angle represents this is
like up like this right because the arm
at the moment
cyclists body is facing the direction of
the normal did you see that so you can
sort of imagine it's as if there were an
embankment there but there's not an
embankment it's the cyclist that is in
fact okay so what we're now looking at
is this is you're heading out this is
not a bad track what we're looking at
this is a leaning cyclist cyclist now
I'm putting this under a different
heading I'm not calling it like a sunset
of bank tracks because actually the
mechanics that governs a banked track
and locate that covers all these like
this are actually kind of different okay
however within the scope of the course
like we have to treat them as the same
thing because we've got this sort of
supermodel right so here's what I'm
going to do for you this moment we've
already developed right and things like
I mean if you've got your notes there
you might recall turn feet up we've got
an expression for tentative like what
angle should it be should we make the
amazement this expression is going to be
the same for what angle should this
cyclist leaned over and I think it's as
if it is a V squared on gr or are doing
whatever you well I'm pretty sure that's
it yeah ok so this same idea can be can
be used as a successful model to working
out what angle should i incline my
embankment or what angle should my
cyclist Lina ok the mathematics works
fine so in some senses you can treat and
leaning cyclist like a banked track it's
just that they're banking themselves ok
and I'll show you how to do that ok but
but the mechanics actually quite
different to explain it I need to sort
of introducing new concept which is
outside of the scope of the course so
I'll do this first and if you want to
answer all the questions you want on
this simpler understanding that's fine
and you can sort of get on with your
exercises but if you're like me and you
want to actually know what is going on
then i will show you this up that's what
this this setup is all about i will show
you what this extra concept is a fixed
into the room were very comfortable i'm
not a physics student so i had to work
time before when I was trying to
understand this back in the day so I
hope if you're in the same position as
me it will make sense to you the way out
to me okay so this is going to be a
lesson in to act number one let's just
do the simplified model and then number
two let's work out let's let's dig
deeper see what's going on okay so if
you're with me make a little subheading
which is a simplified model what
picturing now is a leading cyclist so
see this diagram here the ground itself
has been in close okay but the whole
bullying cyclist is that the ground is
not inclined you're on a flat surface
okay so draw a flat surface for me so
here is the ground now what I want to
picture therefore is the cyclist is what
is leaning over the cyclist is leaning
over so therefore I'm going to draw the
cyclist like this there's the cyclist
leaning into a turn okay in fact maybe
you want to indicate is this way is the
direction nothing turning you okay so
from our perspective they're turning to
their right and we'll stay with that
okay